que mueren cada año antes de cumplir 5 años.
Y encontramos
una historia de éxito fenomenal,
que no es muy conocida,
de un avance increíble.
Pasamos de 20 millones
no mucho después de mi nacimiento
a estar ahora por debajo de los 6 millones.
Así que esta es una historia
principalmente de vacunas.
La viruela mataba a un par de millones de niños al año.
Fue erradicada, así que bajó a cero.
El sarampión mataba un par de millones al año.
Ha bajado a unos pocos cientos de miles.
Como sea, esta es una gráfica
donde se quiere conseguir que esa cifra continúe,
y será posible,
mediante la ciencia de nuevas vacunas,
produciendo las vacunas para los niños.
De hecho podemos acelerar el progreso.
En la última década,
esa cifra ha bajado más rápido
que nunca antes en la historia,
y por eso me encanta decir
está bien, si podemos inventar nuevas vacunas
podemos sacarlos de allí,
usar la explicación más moderna
y hacer el reparto correcto, para poder hacer un milagro.
CA: Hacen los cálculos,
y funciona, literalmente,
para salvar miles de vidas de niños cada año
en comparación con el año anterior.
No se informa.
Un avión de pasajeros con más de 200 muertes
es una historia mucho más importante que esa.
¿Eso los vuelve locos?
BG: Sí, porque es algo que ocurre en silencio.
Es un niño, un niño a la vez.
El 98 % de esto
no tiene nada que ver con desastres naturales
y, sin embargo, la ayuda de la gente,
cuando ven un desastre natural, es asombrosa.
Es increíble cómo la gente piensa,
"Ese podría ser yo", y el dinero fluye.
Estas causas han sido un poco invisibles.
Ahora que se conocen los Objetivos de Desarrollo del Milenio
y se conocen varias cosas,
estamos viendo una mayor generosidad,
así que la meta es llegar a muy por debajo del millón,
lo cual debería ser posible durante nuestra vida.
CA: Tal vez se necesitaba a alguien
conmovido por números y gráficos
en lugar de solo la cara grande y triste,
para comprometerse.
Usaste eso en tu carta este año,
usaste básicamente este argumento para decir que ayudar,
contrario a la idea actual
de que la ayuda es algo sin valor, que no funciona,
de hecho ha sido efectiva.
BG: Sí, bueno la gente puede ver,
hay alguna ayuda bien intencionada
que no salió bien.
Hay algunas inversiones de capital de riesgo
bien intencionadas que no salieron bien.
No deberíamos decir, está bien, gracias a eso,
porque no tenemos un resultado perfecto,
este es un mal proyecto.
Debemos decir: ¿cuál era el objetivo?
¿Cómo tratamos de mejorar la nutrición,
la supervivencia y la alfabetización
para que estos países puedan cuidar de sí mismos?
Y decir: ¡Vaya, esto va bien!
Y ser más inteligentes.
Podemos emplear la ayuda más inteligentemente.
No todo es una panacea.
Podemos hacerlo mejor que el capital de riesgo, en mi opinión,
incluyendo grandes éxitos como este.
CA: La sabiduría tradicional dice
que es muy difícil para los matrimonios trabajar juntos.
¿Cómo lo han manejado Uds.?
MG: Sí, me han dicho muchas mujeres:
"Creo que no podría trabajar con mi marido.
Simplemente no funcionaría".
Saben, lo disfrutamos, y nosotros no...
esta fundación ha sido un acercamiento para ambos
en este aprendizaje continuo,
y no viajamos tanto juntos
para la fundación, como solíamos hacerlo
cuando Bill trabajaba en Microsoft.
Tenemos viajes a los que vamos por separado,
pero siempre sé que cuando regreso a casa,
Bill va a estar interesado en lo que aprendí,
ya sea sobre las mujeres o las niñas
o algo nuevo sobre el sistema de entrega de vacunas,
o de esta persona que es un gran líder.
Él va a escuchar y va a estar muy interesado.
Y sabe que cuando él regresa a casa,
incluso si es para hablar del discurso que dio
o de datos o de lo que aprendió,
que estoy muy interesada,
y creo que tenemos una verdadera relación de colaboración.
Pero no estamos todo el tiempo juntos, eso seguro.
(Risas)
CA: Pero ahora lo están, y estamos muy felices de que lo estén.
Melinda, desde el principio, estuviste básicamente
a cargo del programa.
Hace 6 años, creo,
Bill se integró tiempo completo, salió de Microsoft
y se incorporó tiempo completo.
Debió haber sido difícil,
ajustarse a eso, ¿no?
MG: Sí. Creo que en realidad,
por parte de los empleados de la fundación,
hubo mucha más angustia
que de mi parte por la llegada de Bill.
De hecho yo estaba muy entusiasmada.
Es decir, Bill tomó esta decisión
incluso obviamente antes de que fuera anunciada en 2006,
y fue realmente su decisión,
otra vez, fue durante unas vacaciones en la playa,
cuando caminábamos por la playa
y él empezaba a pensar en esta idea.
Y, para mí, la emoción de Bill
de poner su cerebro y su corazón
al servicio de estos grandes problemas mundiales,
estas injusticias, para mí era emocionante.
Sí, los empleados de la fundación estaban angustiados por eso.
(Aplausos)
CA: Muy bien.
MG: Pero eso desapareció después de 3 meses,
una vez que él estuvo allí
BG: Incluyendo a algunos de los empleados.
MG: Eso fue lo que dije, los empleados,
desapareció para ellos 3 meses después de que llegaste.
BG: No, estoy bromeando. MG: Los empleados no se fueron.
BG: Algunos de ellos se fueron, pero...
(Risas)
CA: Y ¿sobre qué discuten?
Domingo, 11 en punto,
no están en el trabajo,
¿qué surge? ¿Cuál es la discusión?
BG: Como construimos esto
juntos desde el principio,
existe esta gran alianza.
Tuve eso con Paul Allen
en los primeros días de Microsoft.
Lo tenía con Steve Ballmer cuando Microsoft se hacía más grande,
y ahora Melinda, y aún de manera más fuerte,
de igual manera, es la socia,
así que hablamos mucho sobre:
¿a qué deberíamos darle prioridad?
¿Qué grupos están trabajando mejor?
Ella tiene muchas ideas.
Se sienta mucho con los empleados.
Hacemos los viajes que describió.
Hay mucha colaboración.
No puedo pensar en algo en que uno de nosotros
tuvo una opinión muy firme
sobre una cosa u otra.
CA: ¿Y qué hay de ti, Melinda? ¿Puedes? (Risas)
Nunca se sabe.
MG: Bueno, esto es lo que pasa.
Nos aproximamos a las cosas desde diferentes ángulos,
y de hecho pienso que eso es muy bueno.
Así que Bill puede ver los grandes datos
y decir: "Quiero actuar con base en estas estadísticas globales".
Yo llego a ellas por intuición.
Me reúno con mucha gente sobre el terreno
y Bill me enseñó a confrontar esa realidad
con los datos globales y ver si coinciden,
y yo le he enseñado
a tomar esos datos
y reunirse con gente en el terreno para entender,
¿se puede en verdad entregar esa vacuna?
¿Se puede hacer que una mujer acepte esas vacunas contra la polio
en la boca de su hijo?
Porque la parte de entrega
es tan importante como la ciencia.
Así que pienso que ha sido más el acercarse con el tiempo
hacia el punto de vista del otro,
y, francamente, el trabajo es mejor gracias a eso.
CA: En vacunas y polio y así sucesivamente,
han tenido algunos éxitos sorprendentes.
¿Qué pasa con el fracaso?
Pueden hablar sobre el fracaso
y tal vez de lo que han aprendido de él.
BG: Sí. Afortunadamente, podemos permitirnos algunos fracasos,
porque ciertamente los hemos tenido.
Trabajamos mucho con medicamentos y vacunas
en los que sabes que vas a tener diferentes fallas.
Por ejemplo, proyecto que tuvo mucha publicidad,
requería un mejor condón.
Tenemos cientos de ideas.
Quizás algunas de ellas funcionaran.
Fuimos muy ingenuos, ciertamente lo fui, con un medicamento
para una enfermedad en la India, leishmaniasis visceral,
que pensé, una vez que consiga este fármaco,
podemos erradicar la enfermedad.
Bueno, resulta que se necesitó una inyección
diaria durante 10 días.
Fueron necesarios 3 años más de lo que esperábamos,
y luego no había manera
de eliminarla.
Afortunadamente, descubrimos
que si matas a las moscas de la arena,
probablemente tengas éxito.
Pero pasamos 5 años,
se puede decir que desperdiciamos 5 años,
y cerca de USD 60 millones,
en algo que resultó tener
un beneficio muy modesto cuando lo conseguimos.
CA: Gastan, cerca de, USD 1000 millones al año
en educación, creo, algo así.
La historia de lo que ha salido bien
es un tanto larga y compleja.
¿Ha habido algunos fracasos que nos puedan contar?
MG: Yo diría que una gran lección para nosotros
es que pensamos
que estas escuelas pequeñas eran la respuesta,
y las escuelas pequeñas definitivamente ayudan.
Reducen la tasa de deserción.
Tienen menos violencia y crimen.
Pero en ese trabajo aprendimos,
que la pieza fundamental
es un gran maestro en el aula.
Si no tienes un maestro eficaz
en el aula,
no importa qué tan grande o pequeño sea el lugar,
no se podrá cambiar la trayectoria
de ese estudiante hacia la universidad.
(Aplausos)
CA: Melinda, esta eres tú
y tu hija mayor, Jenn.
Fue tomada hace solo 3 semanas,
hace 3 o 4 semanas. ¿Dónde fue esto?
MG: Fuimos a Tanzania.
Jenn ha estado en Tanzania.
Todos nuestros hijos han estado mucho en África.
Hicimos algo muy diferente,
que fue, que decidimos pasar
2 noches y 3 días con una familia.
Anna y Sanare son los padres.
Nos invitaron a ir y quedarnos en su boma.
Incluso, las cabras estuvieron ahí, creo,
viviendo en esa pequeña choza
dentro su pequeño recinto antes de que llegáramos.
Y nos quedamos con su familia,
y verdaderamente aprendimos
como es la vida en la Tanzania rural.
Y la diferencia entre solo ir
y visitar medio día
o 3/4 de día
a quedarse toda la noche fue grande,
y te lo explicaré.
Ellos tuvieron 6 hijos, y hablando con Anna
en la cocina, cocinamos casi 5 horas
ese día en la choza,
y hablando con ella, ella había planeado
y espaciado con su esposo
los nacimientos de sus hijos.
Era una relación muy amorosa.
Eran un guerrero masái y su esposa,
que decidieron casarse,
claramente había respeto y amor en su relación.
Sus hijos, sus 6 hijos,
los 2 del medio eran gemelos, tenían 13 años,
un niño, y una niña llamada Grace.
Y cuando salimos a cortar madera
y hacer todas las cosas que Grace y su madre hacían,
Grace no era una niña, era una adolecente,
pero no era adulta.
Era muy, muy tímida.
Quería hablar conmigo y con Jenn.
Tratábamos de abordarla, pero era tímida.
Aunque en la noche,
cuando todas las luces se apagaron en la zona rural de Tanzania,
y no había luna esa noche,
la primera noche, y sin estrellas,
y Jenn salió de nuestra choza
con su pequeña lámpara para la cabeza,
Grace salió de inmediato,
tomó el traductor,
fue directo hacia mi Jenn y dijo:
"Cuando te vayas a casa
¿podrías dejarme tu lámpara
para estudiar por las noches?".
CA: ¡Vaya!
MG: Y su padre me había dicho
que tenía miedo que, a diferencia de su hijo,
que había pasado sus exámenes de secundaria,
por sus quehaceres,
ella no hubiera salido tan bien
y aún no estaba en la escuela pública.
Él dijo: "No sé cómo voy a pagar su educación.
No puedo pagar una escuela privada,
y ella tal vez termine en esta granja como mi esposa".
Así que ellos conocen la diferencia
que la educación puede marcar
de manera significativa.
CA: Esta es otra foto
de sus otros 2 hijos, Rory y Phoebe,
junto a Paul Farmer.
Criar a 3 niños
siendo la familia más rica del mundo
parece un experimento social
sin precedentes.
¿Cómo lo han logrado?
¿Cuál ha sido su enfoque?
BG: Bueno, yo diría que en general
los niños reciben una gran educación,
pero hay que asegurarse
de que conozcan su propia capacidad
y hacia dónde van, qué van a hacer.
Nuestra filosofía ha sido
ser muy claros con ellos;
la mayor parte del dinero se va a la fundación
y los ayudamos a encontrar algo que los apasione.
Queremos lograr un equilibrio donde tengan
la libertad de hacer cualquier cosa
pero no colmarlos con mucho dinero
para que terminen sin hacer nada.
Hasta ahora, están muy aplicados,
entusiasmados de abrirse su propio camino.
CA: Han resguardado su privacidad cuidadosamente por razones obvias.
Tengo curiosidad por saber por qué me han permitido
mostrar esta fotografía aquí en TED.
MG: Bueno, es interesante.
A medida que crecen, saben muy bien
que nuestra ideología familiar tiene base en la responsabilidad,
que nos encontramos en una situación increíble
solo por vivir en EE.UU.
y tienen una gran educación,
y tenemos la responsabilidad de devolverle al mundo.
Así, a medida que crecen
y les enseñamos,
han visitado muchos países del mundo,
dicen,
queremos que las personas sepan que creemos
en lo que están haciendo, mamá y papá,
y está bien que nos muestren más.
Así que tenemos su permiso para mostrar esta fotografía.
Y creo que Paul Farmer probablemente va a ponerla
eventualmente en alguno de sus trabajos.
Pero realmente les importa profundamente,
también, la misión de la fundación.
CA: Tienen suficiente dinero
a pesar de su enorme contribución a la fundación
para convertirlos en multimillonarios.
¿Ese es su plan para ellos?
BG: No. No. Ellos no tendrán nada de eso.
Necesitan tener la sensación
de que su propio trabajo es significativo e importante.
Leímos un artículo hace mucho, en realidad antes de casarnos,
donde Warren Buffett habló de eso,
y estamos muy convencidos de que eso no le sirve
ni a la sociedad, ni a los niños.
CA: Hablando de Warren Buffett,
sucedió algo verdaderamente asombroso en 2006,
cuando de algún modo tu único verdadero rival
para la persona más rica de EE.UU.
de repente decidió donar
el 80 % de su fortuna
a tu fundación.
¿Cómo sucedió eso?
Supongo que hay una versión larga y una versión corta.
Tenemos tiempo para la versión corta.
BG: Muy bien. Bueno, Warren era un amigo cercano,
e iba a hacer que su esposa Suzie
donara todo.
Trágicamente, ella murió antes de que él se lo pidiera.
Y él es bueno para delegar...
(Risas)
Él dijo...
CA: Tuitea eso.
BG: Si hay alguien que está haciendo algo bien,
y está dispuesto a hacerlo sin cobrar,
tal vez eso está bien. Pero estábamos sorprendidos.
MG: Totalmente sorprendidos. BG: Nunca lo hubiéramos esperado,
y ha sido increíble.
Nos ha permitido incrementar nuestra ambición
en lo que la fundación puede hacer, de manera espectacular.
La mitad de los recursos que tenemos
provienen de la alucinante generosidad de Warren.
CA: Y creo que has prometido
que para cuando te retires,
el 95 % o más de tu fortuna,
será donada a la fundación.
BG: Sí.
CA: Y ya que esta relación... si es increíble,
(Aplausos)
Y recientemente, Warren y tú
han estado de un lado para otro tratando de persuadir
a otros multimillonarios y a gente exitosa
de que se comprometan a donar,
más de la mitad de sus activos para la filantropía.
¿Cómo va eso?
BG: Conseguimos cerca de 120 personas
quienes ahora han asumido este compromiso de donar.
Lo genial es que nos reunimos
cada año y decimos:
¿Contratamos personal? ¿Qué les damos?
No tratamos de homogeneizarlo.
Digo, la belleza de la filantropía
es esta diversidad asombrosa.
La gente dona a ciertas cosas.
Vemos y decimos: "Vaya".
Pero eso es grandioso.
Ese es el rol de la filantropía,
elegir enfoques diferentes,
integrados incluso en un solo espacio, como la educación.
Necesitamos más experimentación.
Pero ha sido maravilloso, conocer a estas personas,
compartir su viaje a la filantropía,
cómo involucran a sus hijos,
lo están haciendo de forma diferente,
y ha tenido mucho más éxito de lo que esperábamos.
Ahora parece que va seguir creciendo
en los próximos años.
MG: Y que la gente vea que otras personas
están logrando el cambio a través de la filantropía,
es decir, estas son personas que han
creado sus propios negocios,
pusieron su propio ingenio detrás de ideas increíbles.
Si pusieran sus ideas y su cerebro
detrás de la filantropía, podrían cambiar el mundo.
Y empezar a ver a otros haciendo esto, y decir:
"Vaya, quiero hacer eso con mi propio dinero".
Para mí, esa es la parte increíble.
CA: Tengo la impresión de que es difícil
para algunas personas entender
cómo gastar tanto dinero
en otros.
Hay aquí probablemente algunos multimillonarios
y seguramente algunas personas de éxito.
Tengo curiosidad, ¿podrías vender la idea?
¿Cuál es la idea?
BG: Es lo más gratificante
que hemos hecho,
y no te lo llevas contigo
y si no es bueno para tus hijos,
reunámonos a pensar ideas
sobre lo que podemos hacer.
El mundo es un lugar mucho mejor
gracias a los filántropos del pasado,
y la tradición de EE.UU., es que lo más fuerte,
es la envidia del mundo.
Y parte de la razón por la que soy optimista
es porque pienso que la filantropía
va a crecer
y tomará algunos de estos temas
en los que el gobierno no es tan eficaz
y arrojará algo de luz en la dirección correcta.
CA: El mundo tiene una desigualdad terrible,
un problema de desigualdad creciente
que parece estructural.
Me parece que si más de sus colegas
siguieran el criterio que Uds. han tomado,
tendría un impacto
en ese problema y ciertamente
en la percepción de ese problema.
¿Es un comentario justo?
BG: Claro que sí. Si le quitas a los más ricos
y le das a los menos ricos, es bueno.
Se trata de equilibrar, y eso es justo.
MG: Pero cambias los sistemas.
En EE.UU., tratamos de cambiar el sistema educativo
así que es justo para todos
y funciona para todos los estudiantes.
Eso, para mí, realmente cambia
el balance de desigualdad.
BG: Eso es lo más importante.
(Aplausos)
CA: Bueno, creo que la mayoría de las personas aquí
y muchos millones en el mundo
están impresionados por la trayectoria
que sus vidas han tomado
y el grado espectacular en que
le han dado forma al futuro.
Muchas gracias por venir a TED,
por compartir con nosotros y por todo lo que hacen.
BG: Gracias. MG: Gracias.
(Aplausos)
BG: Gracias. MG: Muchas gracias.
BG: Bien, buen trabajo. (Aplausos)